the beginning of this show though Wow
[Music]
the boys so the boys is a series on
Amazon Prime video I was inundated with
requests to review this thing the only
thing I saw was the poster I was like
let me guess the plot from that poster
group of guys I'll come back to their
home town and find out criminals have
taken over their hometown they gotta
fight the crime No all right it's the
outsiders - what is it oh it's about
superheroes I couldn't have called that
from that I very recently found out that
the boys is actually adapted from a
comic series and that poster is actually
a callback to one of the covers I didn't
know that yeah
superheroes kind of super people super
[ __ ] it's really what it is and
there are a few character story's
character plots to start getting drawn
together one of which is it's one dude
who really has an axe to grind against
the flash characters not the flash to
Karl Urban takes him under his wing
because he has an axe to grind with the
seven as well one girl who's a new
member of the seven she's all idealistic
wants to do good she's like I want to be
a superhero I want to do good so she's
now a part of what's called the seven
which is straight-up the Justice League
but not the Justice League but she finds
out hey they're dicks and I really dug
this show like there have been shows
that have come around that take the
superhero genre and bring it down to us
and bring it down to our level make it
feel like oh it's gritty and real -
Nolan Batman's heroes season 1 anyone
daredevil I'm Netflix like they all kind
of did that this takes it next-level
funny enough the very beginning these
people were talking and I was like this
world is where heroes was the heroes
after birth or whatever this is what it
should have been it would have been a
more interesting story than what we got
and if for nothing else the boys I feel
like the boys is a great peek behind the
curtain for a lot of the entertainment
industry a lot of it is smokescreen a
lot of its illusion a lot of its likes
retweets public perception marketability
sponsorship just given the people what
they want with just fake nonsense
Instagram models like just woke up no
you didn't you have a crew doing your
hair and makeup they're owned by a
company which is a very real part of
entertainment and I enjoyed seeing that
I like the fact that this show addresses
that that's why people flock to YouTube
it's like oh that shit's all fake let's
go to real people then companies came in
to YouTube and now they took over the
space of YouTube and now we're in the
same boat we work with TV it deals with
that I really appreciated that because
it's a big part of our culture now
superheroes and fake [ __ ] that we
think is real this takes both of those
is like hey we'll make a show about
because at no point do you feel like
these people are heroes these these
seven are definitely not heroes they're
they're entertainers that's what they
are they're entertainers with
superpowers and when the cameras are off
it's like their real selves come out I
just they're [ __ ] and you know what
if there was a Justice League if there
were a group of Avengers they'd probably
be [ __ ] too because human nature
meets superpowers should never happen
some are shitty at the gates some are
completely shitty it's complicated I
just I don't want to tell you who's a
[ __ ] and who's not you will find out
as you watch the show it's part of the
interest part of the intrigue it's like
are they all scumbags oh they're not
where does it where's the line-drawing
but it totally throws a tomato in the
face of the idea of like oh these
super-powered people these super people
they would be so good and a big thing
this show does is it's not really
talking about superheroes it's using
superheroes to talk about human beings
and it touched on the darkness and
dangers of human nature if it's given
too much power which sometimes in life
it is I'm not gonna say this is the
first superhero story to do that because
well Watchmen does exist and before
Watchmen who knows something else might
have but I just always think of Watchmen
but social media wasn't around when
Watchmen was made so it takes that
concept and brings it into our decade
instead of doomsday clocks and cold war
threat of nuclear war it's social media
and public perception this show came out
at the right time just per everything
because of everything because of us
because of society because of
entertainment because of how we are and
what we like this is the perfect show to
watch I mean it's gritty added grit he's
not even the word it's very adult this
show is so good at tone and atmosphere
you know like when home Landers talking
to somebody you're like I don't know and
I'm scared and you should be scared you
know if Superman was real
we'd be scared of it the dude is
literally a God who could just wreck the
world if he wanted to but in this one
you really feel like you're like this
guy could just kill everybody if he
wanted to and it freaks me out and I
like that I like that in the face of the
Justice League I'm they're scared out of
my mind that's just that that brought it
to that was next-level real for me and
that's masterful execution that is key
to the entire show and if the show
didn't properly illustrate that if the
audience didn't feel it it just would
have fallen on his face as it stands no
well execute it's also funny too but
it's not like em see you funny MC use
like you know jokes jokes jokes these
are the really messed up comebacks that
people have when they're arguing
bickering their friends just hanging out
just one guy's pulls an answer for
something out of nowhere his friend goes
yeah how far up your ass did you have to
pull that he goes I don't know how deep
does your tongue go like that's amazing
it's just good dialogue you don't find
that in the MCU so when I say humor it's
not the same side note if you guys ever
want to read a comic book that actually
does touch on moral ambiguity like a
little more complex in the DC universe
try identity crisis thought it was great
so there you go come for the review stay
for the recommendation of a comic book
identity crisis it's not like the boys
but I thought was a neat change and
shift in tone for the Justice League you
might enjoy it please the boys had a lot
for me it's all about people who were
like dude this is like right up your
alley guess what Wow it's about
super-powered people who completely
parallel the Justice League who were
monetized by a corporation who dominate
entertainment and social media and it's
a [ __ ] smokescreen I'm telling you
it's just telling the story of 2019 it's
a great binge eight episodes long that
landlord what a way to go my boy is that
weird Elizabeth shoes in the show and
the thing I'm most excited about is I'm
like okay so she totally is gonna be in
Cobra Kai season 3 right that's cool all
right so the boys have you seen it why
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more I know I just chuckled
when I said comment below let me know I
just had the vision of these kids like I
am say I have to wait for my parents to
go to sleep it's not my moral obligation
to say don't watch the boys if you're a
kid and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to sin e more
[Music]
you
[Music]